most of Tucker Carlson tonight Tucker
Carlson himself Tucker good to have you
with us tonight your observations so far
either the Florida race is just amazing
I would add that it wasn't just
Republicans who thought that Andrew
Gilliam would be easy to knock off but a
lot of Democrats I know in Washington
were convinced they would never win this
seat with him running I mean that was
there was a primary the Democratic side
as you know as well here was a guy who
was in some way implicated an FBI
investigation would not explain that in
fact called anyone who questioned him
racist for asking one-term mayor of
Tallahassee one hundred and twenty sixth
largest city in America and running on a
platform that was unapologetically
left-wing if he wins Florida of course
it has implications as you noted for the
presidential race but it also has much
deeper implications for both parties
what does that mean exactly how did that
happen I agree that DeSantis maybe
wasn't the strongest cannon perhaps Adam
Putnam might have one but the fact is if
if Gilliam wins that raises a lot of
questions that I would say that there
are probably two answers and it's the
obvious it's immigration and the economy
immigration has changed Florida in a
very recognizable way the California of
30 years ago was solidly Republicans so
was Florida they now have different
people living in them and so they have
different electoral results that has
kind of taken place beneath the notice I
would say of most people paying
attention and the second is the economy
which is weaker in ways that we in
Washington don't proceed so the
conventional measures of the economy are
GDP and market performance and both of
them are great but if you look at other
indicators slightly beneath the surface
you see that there are a lot of poor
people for example the single most
common living living arrangement for
young people right now is with their
parents I don't think there's been a
time after the Industrial Revolution
when that's been true in this country
and that means that questions like
health care are much more real than they
have been even three cycles ago I mean
Republicans won what 63 was 63 seats in
the 2010 midterm on the back of
Obamacare opposing Obamacare
Andrew Gilliam proposing universal
health care in effect Medicaid for all
which he has is written off as most
people in Washington as a pipe dream and
ludicrous and I think is a mathematical
question
ludicrous there's no way to pay for that
but it definitely resonates with a state
that's poorer than it looks
and so I think as Republicans think
about how did this happen how did
someone who is not as impressive as you
would imagine a governor of a major
state would need to be Andrew Gilliam
how did he win if indeed he does win I
think those it's important to think
through what's actually happening here
you know what I'm done with Russia or
stormy Daniels there's real stuff going
on yeah I think you're absolutely right
and he also I think has built a
grassroots campaign from the beginning
he sort of arrived on the scene a lot of
people didn't know who he was as you say
he's the mayor of you know relatively
smaller city in the United States but
his his his appeal I think that's also
something that I'm kind of watching in
terms of the trend of the evening
charismatic appealing candidates
appeared to be doing you know fairly
well I mean we'll see what happens there
were perhaps recruited well in other
words absolutely but they didn't but I
would argue in this case they didn't I
mean I don't think if you would if you
had assembled a group of 20 democratic
political consultants in DC and said
draw your dream candidate I don't think
it would have been Gilliam I think they
would have wanted someone who maybe
looked like Gilliam and had the manner
of Gilliam but I don't think they would
want someone with the hard left politics
of Gilliam I they were they thought he
was going to lose again I'm having
talked to them and so I think maybe the
hard left economic issues are a little
bit more popular than we want to think
they are I think that's person I think
that's ominous but it doesn't make it
any less true so why is it that beta or
arc for example I think we'll probably
lose tonight but he's coming a lot
closer that he should be in the state of
Texas again to causes immigration has
changed the demographics in Texas and to
some of this populist economic stuff is
more popular again than we want to think
it is